il ya quelques jours j'ai présenté les
premières cartes de la france avant la
levée du confinement
ces cartes ce sont des outils qui nous
ont guidés et qui continueront de nous
guider
au cours des prochaines semaines parce
qu'elles sont le reflet de la
circulation du virus sur le territoire
également le reflet du niveau de
saturation des services de réanimation
dans nos hôpitaux
ces cartes elles ont pu soulever des
inquiétudes désespoir mais aussi parfois
des incompréhensions selon la couleur
verte orange ou rouge
aussi je le précise bien si votre
département est en rouge
ce n'est ni une punition ni une mauvaise
note
ce n'est qu'un état des lieux de la
situation viral sur un territoire donné
qui tient compte de données multiples je
le disais le premier indicateur c'est
celui de la circulation active du virus
les chiffres dont nous disposons sont
issus d'un recueil de données robuste
fiable quotidien ils proviennent de
presque 700 services d'urgence et permet
de comptabiliser environ 90% des
passages aux urgences
ils sont publiés quotidiennement et font
une moyenne des informations recueillies
sur les sept jours précédents
nous constatons et vous constaté depuis
les premières cartes que la pression
épidémique a baissé mais cette baisse
cache en réalité des disparités des
différences parfois importantes selon
les territoires
si l'on affiné que l'on regarde
territoire par territoire
la situation est la suivante je la
rappelle envers les départements dans
lesquels -2 6% des patients adressés aux
urgences viennent pour une suspicion de
maladie au corona virus en orange
lorsque ce sont 6 à 10 % des patients et
en rouge c'est lorsque plus de 10% des
patients qui vont aux urgences d'un
hôpital
ils vont pour une suspicion de maladie à
coronavirus comme vous pouvez le
constater ci la circulation du virus
semble faible sur très large partie du
territoire
elle demeure encore actives dans
certains départements des hautes france
grand test de bourgogne franche comté
dans la sarthe et le loir et cher et
elle atteint un niveau bien plus élevé
en ile-de-france et une circulation
active est également enregistrée à
mayotte
j'en viens maintenant à la seconde carte
celle que vous connaissez aussi qui
relatives aux capacités sanitaires entre
janvier et mars
nous avons augmenté notre capacité de
réanimation pour atteindre le chiffre
sans précédent dans notre histoire
sanitaire de dix mille cinq cents lits
notre objectif désormais est de revenir
à notre capacité habituelle c'est-à-dire
fin me lit de réanimation au pouvoir
prendre à nouveau en charge des malades
qui ont besoin dans la pratique
quotidienne de la médecine et de la
chirurgie de ces lits de réanimation
et puis pour permettre aux
professionnels de santé de retrouver un
fonctionnement normal
et puis c'est bien la moindre des choses
un peu de répit il faut bien comprendre
que les tensions sur les capacités en
réanimation du fait de l'épidémie reste
encore forte dans certains territoires
compte tenu de l'afflux important de
patients graves dans les service de réa
de nos hôpitaux ces dernières semaines
c'est le cas dans les régions qui ont
été le plus touché l'île de france le
grand test
la bourgogne franche comté et a minima
dans les hauts de france le centre val
de loire
l'auvergne rhône-alpes et mayotte dans
le reste du territoire
la situation est revenue sinon à la
normale en tout cas dans des eaux bien
plus acceptable là aussi les résultats
qui sont affichés sont une moyenne sur
les sept derniers jours les seuils
utilisé pour cette deuxième carte vous
les avez sur la carte en verre lorsque
le taux d'occupation des lits de
réanimation par des malades du
coronavirus est inférieur à 60% en
orange lorsque ces 60 à 80%
et lorsque plus de 80 % des lits de
réanimation sont occupés par des malades
atteints du coronavirus la carte
apparaît alors en rouge comme vous
pouvez le constater la situation est
assez net avec au fond trois diagonales
distinctes dans l'hexagone
la première diagonale en verre va de la
seine maritime aux alpes-maritimes
avec des capacités hospitalières qui ne
sont pas ou plus menacé par un afflux
important de patients atteints de formes
sévères
la seconde diagonale celle qui était
affiche en orange va du pas de calais à
la haute savoie avec des services de
réanimation davantage mis en tension par
l'hospitalisation persistante de
patients atteints de formes graves de
coronavirus la troisième diagonale enfin
celle qui est en rouge qui comprend
essentiellement les départements des
régions grand test île de france
bourgogne franche comté
c'est cette diagonale dans laquelle la
situation des services de réanimation
reste l'objet d'une attention toute
particulière
s'agissant maintenant de la troisième
carte que vous allez découvrir
aujourd'hui c'est celle de nos capacités
en matière de tests virologiques en
janvier 2020 le premier test pcr à la
recherche du virus coville 19 a été
réalisé depuis nous n'avons cessé
d'augmenter jour après jour semaine
après semaine
nos capacités de diagnostic en ville à
l'hôpital dans les laboratoires
départementaux vétérinaire de
gendarmerie afin de pouvoir
diagnostiquer de nouvelles infections
un effort de montée en charge et de
renforcement des équipements très
important a été réalisé pour armer notre
pays
en test ces dernières semaines tout a
été fait pour être en capacité de
dépister les personnes vulnérables mais
aussi l'ensemble des personnes
symptomatique et les cas contactez la
france est prête pour tester massivement
la capacité de dépistage et dès
aujourd'hui au niveau des besoins
estimés
vous voyez la carte est pour le moins
limpide
pourtant parfois de la théorie à la
pratique il peut y avoir des écarts
c'est pourquoi j'invite les français qui
se serait vu prescrire un test pcr et
qui rencontrerait des difficultés de
toute nature dans la réalisation de ce
test à contacter le numéro vert 0 800
130 000
le numéro que vous connaissez afin de
nous permettre de résoudre sans délai
les problèmes éventuels
comme vous pouvez le constater les
territoires seront dans leur totalité en
capacité de tester largement j'en
termine donc par une carte qui fait la
synthèse des différents indicateurs et
qui se présente comme une photographie
comme un panorama de la situation des
territoires français à compter du 11 mai
cette carte articule les trois
indicateurs de pression épidémique de
tension sanitaire et de capacités en
matière de tests vous le voyez quatre
régions tous les départements de quatre
régions reste en rouge
l'île de france les hôtes france
bourgogne franche comté et grant est
pourquoi des régions et pas des
départements parce que nous faisons le
choix de tenir compte comme indicateur
prioritaires du niveau de tension de
saturation des réanimation des hôpitaux
et que cet indicateur nous l'avons vu
lors de la vague épidémique dans les
régions touchées
ce qu'on soit à l'échelle régionale en
particulier et le premier ministre l'a
dit la situation en ile de france
nécessite la plus grande des vigilances
nous appelons les entreprises à recourir
au maximum au télétravail nous invitons
les habitants de l'ile-de-france à
limiter leurs déplacements au strict
nécessaire et l'ensemble de la
population à appliquer encore plus
scrupuleusement les gestes barrière
quant aux personnes vulnérables s'il
vous plaît limiter au strict minimum vos
sorties et contact avec toute autre
personne je le redis en ile de france
nous devons faire preuve d'une extrême
vigilance
je sais les difficultés que chacun a
traversé ces dernières semaines et je
sais combien tout le monde souhaite
pouvoir reprendre une vie un peu plus
normale mais nous voulons à tout prix
éviter une reprise de l'épidémie qui
viendraient alourdir encore la situation
de ces territoires
ce sont donc des mesures de précaution
essentielle en cette période que nous
devons respecter tous ensemble
collectivement
voilà où nous en sommes les éléments que
je viens de vous présenter sont fiables
ils sont solides et je le rappelle et
chacun doit avoir doit le garder à
l'esprit
l'épidémie est évolutive et la vérité
d'un jour peut ne pas être celle du
lendemain
j'en appelle donc à ceux qui ne fera
jamais l'objet d'aucune attestation
d'aucune justification est donc une
règle c'est bien l'esprit de
responsabilité de chacun pour le bien de
tous